This lesson is all about relationships and the filters and the measures they facilitate.
We'll start by defining the different relationship types also known as cardinality,
and the filtering of directions of relationships which play
an important role in how data is reflected in reports.
As you will learn in this lesson,
the existence of a relationship doesn't do you any good unless the setup is correct,
and even though Power BI will try to recognize relationships on your behalf,
it's important to know relationships well enough to be able
to determine whether Power BI has helped us in the right way.
From there, we'll go into the handy implicit DAX measures that are built
into Power BI and can be used with a simple click in the reporting pane,
and their slightly more sophisticated sibling, the Quick Measures.
We'll also discuss what filters can be
used in the reporting pane for different data types,
and then we'll cover a couple of
Swiss Army knife-type custom DAX functions that are
commonly used in conjunction with filters and get some practice using them.